es una victoria jurídica para el
gobierno pero sí te está tomando un
riesgo político
el consejo constitucional y habló como
muy bien ligero es la instancia
constitucional institucional más elevada
en materia de derecho y de validación a
la constitución pero obviamente vemos
que el ambiente político queda bastante
tenso tanto como a nivel social Aunque
el fallo adorable sobre todo sobre las
medidas claves como muy bien dijiste
Rosa son las medidas claves del de la
ley obviamente es una victoria jurídica
para para el poder ejecutivo y como
tienen usted lo decía no este fallo está
validando alguno de los puntos más
impopulares de esta ley
seguramente con toda probabilidad esta
decisión no va a ser muy bien acogida
por el movimiento en contra de la
Reforma ni por los sindicatos que se
espera de este movimiento que escenario
se abren
digamos la semana próxima de Mariel
macón llamó a reunirse con los
sindicatos con Los Socios Los
partidarios sociales será martes
entonces ahí vamos a poder medir vamos a
poder medir tanto el ambiente social
vamos a ver si corremos el riesgo de un
estallido social o si vamos hacia una
concertación ahora que pasó el consejo
constitucional eso lo vamos a poder
medir martes pero lo que aparece en la
pregunta que que haces muy legítima es
hemos visto a raíz de los días de
manifestaciones y de huelgas que había
en Francia un movimiento
y lógico social enmarcado por la la
unión intervindical y por los sindicatos
tanto como un movimiento de violencia
que tenía educación política y eso es lo
que apareció en estas semanas a saber un
movimiento social enmarcado por los
sindicatos y que son parterios sociales
de del poder ejecutivo cualquier sea
pero a la vez hubo esa violencia una
violencia de los que hemos visto y que
corría riesgo de desbordar un movimiento
Cívico Social a raíz de de estas
manifestaciones de esos días de
movilización esta semana Tuvimos
una
manifestación número 12
el ayer Pues el jueves pasado Entonces
eso es el ambiente hoy en día con entre
movimientos de los sindicatos muy bien
tu Cívico y un una voluntad desbordar
por movimientos más políticos que sí ahí
ponían en tela de juicio las
instituciones En eso estamos sí Pascal
pero juntando dos elementos que usted
menciona no por un lado el hecho que
Manuel macron ha citado a los sindicatos
la semana que viene lo que bien pone un
poco en cuestión porque llega en este
momento la reunión no la apertura al
diálogo por parte de Manuel macron que
ha rechazado reunirse previamente con
los sindicatos antes de que la reforma
fuera aprobada en la asamblea No de
hecho la reunión incluso con la primera
ministra Elizabeth Von llegó una vez la
reforma también había sido aprobada en
la asamblea con el artículo 49.3 de la
Constitución es decir sin debate no en
el órgano legislativo en la cámara baja
particularmente y precisamente esta
falta de apertura del gobierno al
diálogo ha sido lo que muchos actores
sociales políticos han justificado como
motivo por el cual las manifestaciones
han desbordado de forma violenta no
diciendo que no había alternativa no
había otra forma de que el gobierno
escuchara los reclamos de las calles Por
qué se ha cerrado tanto el gobierno al
diálogo
Pues creo que eso llegó a raíz del
debate primero segundo puede hacer que
haya sido una apuesta y que haya sido
una posición asumida por el poder
ejecutivo en la discusión porque tampoco
podemos decir que no hubo discusión en
el parlamento
dice al final definitivamente es el
proyecto de ley que era un proyecto
rectificatorio financiero
encerrando el debate en un periodo de 50
días permitiendo el uso de un artículo
el que dijiste el 49.3 que fue usado
usado fue usado desde la creación de
nuestra República en 1958 la quinta
República cien veces es decir que
tampoco era algo inédito es un
instrumento del poder legislativo del
poder Perdón ejecutivo que hace
prevalecer El Ejecutivo sobre el
parlamentario legislativo en este tipo
de debate Lo usó el gobierno
definitivamente ahí fue una una posición
una postura de de ir en adelante a a
cualquier diría costo político es por
eso que decían en producción Victoria
jurídica riesgo político porque ahora sí
Por cierto vamos a ver a pesar de la las
discusiones que habrá el martes y a ver
si van a abrir un nuevo ciclo de de
discusión con los sindicatos Pero por
supuesto puede haber también tensión
política Sabiendo el presidente que en
el parlamento
beneficia tiene todavía una mayoría
relativa es decir que a nivel
institucional las instrucciones
funcional y el beneficia de esa fuerza
que le procure pues la legitimidad
ejecutiva ahorra
estamos en un momento sumamente político
estamos en su momento que toca a tema
social que toca el tema del trabajo del
enlace al trabajo de de del desarrollo
de sí mismo también en el trabajo
estamos en temas sensibles y vamos a ver
pues Por cierto a partir de de los días
que vienen Cómo se organiza a nivel
político ahí también podemos tener
varias opciones puede haber una
reducción de movilización la gente
pensando que ya se acabó digamos ahora
que la instancia última habló puede
seguir este malestar esa movilización
lo vamos a ver tomando en cuenta rusa
que existen otros temas también muy de
actualidad la inflación tenemos una
guerra a la puerta de Europa hay todo
este contexto que obliga también pues la
opinión como
El Ejecutivo en ser movilizados y
centrados sobre también esos temas pero
Pascal precisamente este riesgo político
al que usted hace referencia No pues ya
tiene ya ha empezado a manifestarse no a
tener ciertas expresiones de hecho le
Quiero leer a usted y a nuestra
audiencia ya el pronunciamiento de
jeanluca me lanzó en el líder de la
izquierda francesa particularmente de la
Francia insumisa uno de los partidos que
forma parte de la coalición nupes el
tuit dice lo siguiente la decisión del
Consejo constitucional demuestra que
está más atento a las necesidades de la
monarquía presidencial que a las del
pueblo soberano la lucha continúa y debe
reunir sus fuerzas aclaremos que esto de
monarquía presidencial hace referencia
un poco al sistema presidencialista de
la quinta República no que da mucho
poder al presidente y Por ende al
ejecutivo Pascal le pido precisamente no
una una reacción un análisis ya de este
de este pronunciamiento
pues primero es lo que se esperaba de
melonson que moviliza una fracción del
electorado Y definitivamente vimos estas
últimas semanas que la Francia insumisa
que es el el partido que que que que
administró y que fundió tenía la
vocación también de denunciar las
instituciones Entonces en este tú diría
usando la palabra de monarquía cuando
estamos en una República es también un
posicionamiento político lógico por
parte delonso no sé si va a convencer
una amplia
una larga amplitud de del electorado
ahora el tema es más bien estamos al
final del primer año del segundo mandato
de Manuel el presidente francés está
elegido por cinco años reelegible una
vez lo que pasó con Emmanuel es decir
que cuando hablaba de político es porque
todavía le quedan cuatro años de
gobierno cuatro años de Presidencia
estamos apenas al final del primer año
entonces ahí la meta para el presidente
es Buscar el medio a partir de ahora
para relanzarse para reaparecer como un
elemento de unidad cuando muy bien
dijiste Rosa
las opiniones favorables hoy en día
están muy caídas tanto del presidente
como de la jefa